this intro is bumping
[Music]
sorry guys I went I went somewhere I
think we have to do remote play still
guys that's my guess
are you gonna host the Bobby with me to
mate who's making it oh I'll do it Bob
can you invite me again because I forgot
to unmute myself then I tabbed out and
it doesn't work like to because I
couldn't connect to the remote you know
all of you do you have the game open and
then you're trying to join should I have
the game closed yeah we've done this
before we we've covered that exact topic
before if that fixes it when did you
cover that I didn't it the people you
don't how well look there is wait can
you move the menu is that you I was and
now it's all God now everything is
horrible yeah the stream is like
collapsing and it's so fun good wait are
you uploading oh yeah my entire
screenplay for the next film I was
working on oh there's your problem okay
wait for me I can see I can see movement
I can wait wait left and now it works
cannot connect the computer again God
you oh sit I'm watching a 360 p video I
saw whatever I joined can you let me
another one way that I died it's not
happening for me I'm here now oh wait I
think I'm moving it left right up right
left okay that's me yeah alright okay so
what am i doing now party mode yeah I
think so party mode pick those four
carrot boys for turn off your
notifications don't look at those
they're in my recording well
congratulations
I'm not gonna minimize death Mitch yeah
do deathmatch
let's kill each other first I actually
have no idea how to play so I I'm not
I'm pink okay I am nothing I'm yellow at
all me and Mark are faking it what
happened I can't move so I don't even
think I'm here oh no oh my god wait
don't worry I'll do it actually go down
to two or you know funny how it was not
on four I have no idea to make again for
sure
wait what and what you've done you
eighty your arrow keys [ __ ] wait am I
pick wait so space jump I'm pink I'm
definitely paying I'm green well I think
I think oh I'm yellow I'm yellow I'm
yellow apples I really not participate
buttons are cooperating okay I know that
for a fact
sound off I'm a green purple I don't
know no I think I agree ow my neck just
everyone just chill out for a second I
think of us might be pink is anyone is
anyone moving pink right now no no no
somebody else is yellow I'm green I know
this Oh
I'm controlling yellow I think they're
both yellow apparently that doesn't make
the most sense okay
wait we'll take turns it'll be purple oh
God who did this that was me that's me
that's me that's me
purple what are you doing bud oh no no
I'm alive wait
don't go mark now Wade and Jack you just
have to kill three lives on the purple
one without losing it well I think this
is gonna go really well how do you grab
bumpers I I would try clickings maybe or
or there Yoho left left bumper on the
controller seems to work I don't I'm
using keyboard well that's two people
are the same people I've deduced it
everyone it's because he's using a
keyboard wait wait wait it's like
heave-ho all over again all right Sean
you take the last or I got two kills
there here I got this Sean don't you
ruin this for us it's better if you just
don't play apparently got it I did that
birthday I'm four so now we're now we're
maybe four separate people sure yeah
okay I don't even know who I am
okay I'm green again you should be
yellow purple now oh [ __ ] you stopped on
my head bones
[ __ ] murdered all of us in half with
you no no no you broke my neck
two-for-one so many kills here I'm just
absolutely absolutely he just launched
me I'm hiding here kicking is like the
way to win as I I'm just gonna stay
right here no wait we're good be so hard
[Applause]
[Laughter]
we can we can gg
Oh got the strat now yeah we're gonna
release lives in this position I'm
coming for you
[Laughter]
am I so yellow yeah we should be the
same humans wait why are the arguments
I'm very not good as it turns out most
killing myself repeatedly oh don't you
do anything
I don't know I don't want to know come
on push the goddamn ball come on it
don't work very good
you killed me but you knocked yourself
into the pit how's it going pretty good
you can't use my strat against me hey
see see how uncool you guys are for
doing this it's so good so quick this is
where I live now I'm going to oh you
didn't get nobody Frick all I know is
that I have not won so
oh my god okay I'm gonna growl I'm gonna
grab nobody's gonna grab I've got a
death spike you better watch it go why
don't I let go I can't hold like you
guys why sure spike there no probably
you dead forever
yeah I'm out okay so so damn it come
here often
yeah eventually you're in there I will
not
now is the time I think you either win
or suck at this I think there's no
in-between it's a good game isn't it
yeah 360p here we are some really cool
some really cool effects I cannot for
the life of me figure this [ __ ] out I'm
enjoying my tree the only way you can
win Bob no skull god damn you I can't
navigate how do you navigate it's
impossible wait
damnit puppies you kill like that you
killed me on the waiting you panicking
and now I'm dead
we're all dead no you're not all dead
I'm winning this round even if it's me
I'm coming for you just to wait a few
minutes you guys fight it out of my
little palm tree leaf get away from me I
don't want any you crushed me with your
big feets
okay well what I'm seeing what I'm
seeing is it I'm better at killing
myself than you guys you all are
floundering to do what I need to do on a
scale of 1 to how many kills you have
mark is definitely winning I am winning
ya know I grew that neck easy Oh what I
just got on Eileen whoa wait you tease
but it he doesn't know it cuz he's an
idiot
yeah Sean I think we got the strategist
oh wait smells of grass in the morning
this is so good don't you dare come on
our grass pile stacks
I will save you I have grass pocket hey
Mark how's it going ever ah dirt block
is so much better than my grass lawn no
yes block has smelled all the way yes
truth I'm like a horse you startled up
by me I'm just gonna kick scoot away
from you but I want to stay on the block
okay okay okay oh you can see right move
it's way out of lives busy being
aggressive this life I spawned in with a
broken neck what is your strategy
against me it's pretty good oh Jesus I
feel cheap it does feel cheap but fun to
win mark it is fun I do like winning all
right good good
it's fine
I like Kingdom okay now Bob is dead
right here we go all right I'm coming
for you
[Laughter]
[Music]